[Music]
imagine winning a multi-million dollar
lottery tomorrow if you're like many of
us you'd be ecstatic unable to believe
your good luck but would that joy still
be there a few years later maybe not a
famous study of 22 lottery winners
showed that months after winning their
average reported levels of happiness had
increased no more than that of a control
group who hadn't won the lottery some
were actually unhappier than they had
been before winning and later studies
have confirmed that our emotional
well-being how often and how intensely
you feel things like joy sorrow anxiety
or anger don't seem to improve with
wealth or status beyond a certain point
this has to do with a phenomenon known
as hedonic adaptation or the Satanic
treadmill it describes our tendency to
adapt the new situation to maintain a
stable emotional equilibrium when it
comes to feeling happy most of us seem
to have a base level that stays more or
less constant throughout our existence
of course the novelty is better food
superior vacations and more beautiful
homes can at first make you feel like
you're walking on air but as you get
used to those things you revert your
default emotional state that might sound
pretty gloomy but hedonic adaptation
makes us less emotionally sensitive to
any kind of change including negative
ones the study with the lottery winners
also looked at people who had suffered
an accident that left them paralyzed
when asked several months after their
accident how happy they were they
reported levels of happiness approaching
their original baseline
so while the hedonic treadmill may
inhibit our enjoyment of positive
changes it seems to also enable our
resilience in recovering from adversity
there are other reasons that winning the
lottery may not make us happier in the
long run it can be difficult to manage
large sums of money and some lottery
winners wind up spending or losing it
all quickly it can also be socially
isolating some winners experience a
deluge of unwelcome requests for money
so they wind up cutting themselves off
from others and wealth may actually make
us meaner in one study participants
played a rigged game of Monopoly where
the experimenters made some players rich
quickly the wealthy players started
patronizing the poorer layers and
hogging the snacks they were meant to
share but just because a huge influx of
cash isn't guaranteed to bring joy into
your life doesn't mean that money can
never make us happier findings show that
we adapt to extrinsic and material
things like a new car or a bigger house
much faster than we do to novel
experiences like visiting a new place or
learning a new skill
so by that reasoning the more you spend
money on experiences rather than sinks
the happier you be and there's another
way to turn your money into happiness
spend it on other people in one study
participants were given some money and
we're either asked to spend it on
themselves or on coming out later that
evening researchers called up these
participants and asked them how happy
they were to having as levels of those
who had spent the money on others were
significantly greater than that of those
who had spent it on themselves and that
seems to be true around the world
another study examined the generosity of
over 200 thousands in Vil from 136
countries in over 90% of these countries
people who donated tended to be happier
than those who didn't but this all may
be easier said than done let's say a
million dollars falls into your lap
tomorrow what do you do with it
you